man
man let me tell you something okay look
here's the thing man God this is a story
this story is so ridiculously good all
right check this out check this out so
the celestial the progenitor Celestial
the coming together of all the different
celestials kind of hodgepodge together
more or less all Frankenstein this is
the moment when it finally offers its
judgment where it decides whether or not
the entirety of the human race lives or
dies now what this does is this
initially opens up with Captain America
literally at like Central Park right
because that's where the giant X-Men
tree has kind of emerged where you
basically have the the kind of field
base right this is where like the New
York branch the X-Men reside but people
are here because people are turning
against the X-Men population remember
when it came to this whole thing what's
been going on behind the scenes is that
you have had the X-Men and you've had
the eternals and you've had the The
Avengers facing off and kind of joining
forces and then turning against each
other and so on and so forth but the
other big caveat here is that the
picture has been painted that the
mutants or why this is all happening in
the first place the other part of this
is that Humanity has always had a fear
of mutants and so as a result in this
time of desperation people look to the
mutants as being the cause of the
problem now the irony of all this is
Captain America is trying to talk
everybody down and that's one of the
things that we're told right the world
understands its Heroes cannot save them
they must be their own Heroes now they
must decide what hero means and we're
told by the celestial the tests are real
they cannot be sure the World shows its
true face and I watch Captain America
failed his test and praise others do not
do likewise so the man and the flag
tries to inspire people to not bludgeon
one another to death there's riots in
the streets riots and the country riots
in the homes riots and the hearts and
Captain America can't be everywhere and
this is really what the celestial was
hitting at right this is what the
progenitor was hitting at in the last
video that we did when it analyzed
Captain America and called him a failure
because in reality Captain America is a
hero that people look up to he's just
kind of the center of the superhero
Community everybody respects him and the
average person knows who he is but in
times of desperation people will believe
what they want to believe and logic will
fly out the window in replace of an
emotional response people are angry and
they're scared and in their anger and
fear they will become the worst versions
of themselves Captain America's speeches
and talking to them and trying to get
people to calm down it has no bearing
whatsoever so much so that people
actually turn against Captain America
because their thought is not Captain
America is here trying to like talk
reason into us and get us to you know
get to get the day to calm down instead
their Captain America is trying to stand
in the way of us destroying the thing
that will fix everything Captain America
wants us to die and in turn they turn on
him because of that and that's the crazy
thing because at this point we switch
our attention over to Eros now remember
Eros was the revelation of the person
the eternals reached out to to
effectively save them and Eros was a guy
who could do it remember Eros has the
ability to manipulate the emotions of
others he is a pure empath which means
he can live and he can can feel the
emotions of others in a variety of
different ways the funny thing about
this is Eros immediately counters the
point of Iron Man and Cersei and those
guys when their stance is Eros we need
you to use your powers in order to
basically manipulate the emotions of
humanity to essentially instill peace on
a global scale and then the the
celestial will have to rule in our favor
eros's response that's ridiculous if I
do that this Celestia will see right
through it he will immediately know what
it is that's going on that he will see
that in the moment they are peaceful but
the reality is that in their heart of
hearts that they're still just as
terrible as they ever were what has to
be done here in order to bend the
celestial's will to our favor in order
to save our world is to somehow convince
this Celestial that in their heart of
hearts while it may not seem like it
people are inherently good and so what
and what we end up doing here is
actually kind of following the
progenitor as it goes through and starts
analyzing people one of the things it
says is that on his way home angry at
the world Tom passes two other angry men
who decide that he looks kind of Eastern
European and they have strong angry
opinions about that and so they beat him
up because of it the response that the
celestial had is Tom spits out a tooth
and fails to see the irony and so he
fails right the celestial looks to Luke
Cage and says Luke Cage is Mayor this is
his first Extinction event for those of
you guys who aren't familiar with that
when you originally had Kingpin who was
the mayor of New York during like the
entire just crazy situation where
Kingpin basically tried to take over the
city of New York Luke Cage ran against
him since basically attacking Kingpin
would offend would effectively make him
a martyr and would turn people to his
side so Luke Cage ran against him and
won and that's how Luke Cage became
mayor of New York if you guys are
curious about that I'll link the
playlist to that video down in the
description but nonetheless right the
progenitor says he poses as a man of the
press and asks him how do you judge your
performance as mayor and the response of
Luke Cage is a political answer ask me
tomorrow right kind of joking about it a
little bit and sort of easing the
tension and the response of the
progenitor is that is not an option to
take no stance is not an option and he
judges against Luke Cage he then
analyzes Thor and he says Thor Odin's
son fights the themix in orbit Mutual
powers like dueling Sons I observe him
closely I read his Hammer's inscription
and ascertain a Truth by definition he
must be worthy so Thor passes the test
and then he looks to Eros and the funny
thing about this is he doesn't pass
judgment on Eros instead he watches as
Eros just listens to other people Eros
literally travels around the world and
hears people's stories listens to what
they have to say and then just absorbs
that information but the celestial then
turns to Kamala Khan right to Miss
Marvel and he says I appear before
Kamala Khan as Captain Marvel offering
her and her family a chance to leave the
planet escape this and join the secret
higher League of Marvel heroes she
pummels me and demands I tell her what I
did with the real Carol she cannot see
my hand move in her huge fist but she
passes and I vanish now the cool thing
about this and this is what's so ironic
is it's not just the progenitor judging
superheroes it's the progenitor judging
everybody and so one of the things he
says is a woman named Katrina leaves her
hotel room on her way to a rally she's
50 meters down the corridor before she
realizes she forgot a tip she looks at
the distance back knows she's late and
decides not to go back and deliver a tip
and Carries On and the virginiter says I
appear to her in the form of her dead
Aunt with a thumbs down she's mortified
and she asked what did I do and I simply
just don't tell her time and time again
it's the same thing it appears to trial
Xavier as Legion and says I need to talk
Charles Xavier does what he's always
done which is blow off his son and the
celestial judges against him the
celestial continues to watch Eros the
celestial judges the starbread judges in
favor of her the celestial judges a
woman named Daniela as Daniella watches
all the footage going on and in that
moment with daniela's relationship with
her mother being strained at the very
best she decides she needs to be there
for her mom she goes home the celestial
judges in her favor now one of the funny
things that happens here is the
celestial appears to Doctor Doom now you
guys know how Dr Doom is right you guys
know how Victor Von Doom is right
literally the celestial appears and says
I appear to Victor Von Doom and give him
a simple challenge say that Reed
Richards is smarter than you and you
will pass he laughs and then laughs some
more and then leaves he passes himself I
concur like literally Dr Doom's like I'm
not taking your stupid test I decide
that I pass and the celestial is like I
mean oh okay you know but it's again one
of those great moments because then it
appears to Daredevil right and this is
one of those interesting things because
remember Daredevil's Catholic he's a man
of faith and one of the things that
Celestial says is Matt Murdock dresses
as a devil and tries to stop the streets
from becoming Health he is a man with a
firm moral code which he has violated
time and time over I appear with a crown
of thorns and a downturned thumb Beneath
The Mask Matt Murdock weeps he says I
know yet he carries on and that's the
crazy thing it's just one of these
amazing and beautiful moments that goes
on here and so ultimately after
everything that's happened the celestial
continues his judgments of various
people and even superheroes across the
world but then you have Eros who appears
to a coming together of the United
Nations and he literally says okay for
all of you out there here's the thing to
understand and it's really him learning
this Humanity will not come together
just because it's the right thing to do
it's not in the nature of people to do
that the nature of humanity is to be
destructive it's to ruin things destroy
things not necessarily because it's
ingrained in our evolutionary biology
but because it's just what we've been
doing for so long drawing boundaries
over pieces of land to differentiate
between one nation and another one human
being looking at another insane because
of your skin color or your gender or
what have you you're different from me
and that makes you bad just things along
those lines right as primitive as those
ideologies are Eros came to the
realization that Humanity has been doing
it for so long it doesn't know anything
else and so using that to his to his
benefit he approaches the United Nations
and says if you won't come together
because it's the right thing to do then
maybe I can just bribe you to do so
right as it stands right now the X-Men
and the eternals have technology that
you as normal humans simply just don't
have not only that if you are willing to
come together and bring your countries
together and unify in a way that will
save our world then we will also Grant
you Celestial technology not on a
massive scale but something that will
basically help to Usher inhumanity into
a golden age because the reality is we
as eternals have had this technology for
a pretty lengthy amount of time and for
the most part our unwillingness to share
it with you has in a lot of ways been a
failure we could have actually turned
Earth into a golden age but we just
never really did for any number of
reasons the X-Men have recently just
covered this power and they've kept it
selfishly and the celestial power is out
there for Humanity to be used we will
guide you we won't just give it to you
arbitrarily but we will give you the
tools you need to move beyond your
current primitive standpoint of drawing
artificial boundaries that are literally
guaranteed by virtue of just yellow
marks along the road and in turn we will
help you become better and so that's one
of the ideas here is that hopefully it
will lead to a unification of humanity
but the other concern here and the
bigger thing they have to deal with is
Uranus because remember Uranus is one of
the original eternals this guy's so
powerful he's shown up on Mars a planet
full of Omega Level mutants and
eradicated pretty much everybody right
within one hour this guy's on just a
whole different level of power and he's
basically being used by Druid who's the
current leader of the eternals and the
one that really instigated this war in
the first place and so the issue the
eternals have to deal with is their
numbers are fractured their numbers are
split they can't can't just launch an
attack against Druid because he's the
leader of the eternals it'd be like just
assassinating some kind of world leader
you can't do that right because it'll
turn the other eternals against them and
in fact it'll actually incite a civil
war among the eternals what they need is
for Druid to screw up to make a mistake
to do something that will basically lead
to the other eternals losing faith in
him and then voting him out as the prime
Eternal and voting somebody in his stead
but that's the concern when it comes to
dealing with Uranus because their fear
here is that what if Druid will unleash
Uranus on Earth itself what could he
possibly do like imagine the amount of
damage he could inflict here now the
crazy thing about this and the funny
thing about this is that the entire
concern with regards to voting for
drewik is limited to the existing
celestials right they can at any point
in time initiate a vote of no confidence
right they can't at any point in time
the eternals can come along and say we
call for a vote of no confidence in
Druid and we want to elect a new leader
the issue is if they do that their
numbers are split almost perfectly even
if they were to launch that vote what it
would do is it would lead to effectively
the entirety of the the Eternal
landscape staying exactly as it is right
now because those who voted for Druid
are gonna vote for him again those who
voted against him are going to vote
against him again there won't be any
real change what they need is somebody
who can turn the tide and so what
happens here is that druig ultimately
summons the unimod but he does this as a
means to launch a psychic attack against
the Omega Level telepaths on Earth in
the hopes of annihilating all of them
but in his Hubris in doing this and
overlooking and overplaying his hand
what this does is it allows a field team
to infiltrate the exclusion zone right
remember the exclusion zone is the great
machine of the eternals everything that
makes the eternals who they are is is
literally confined to that including the
ability to quote unquote hack into the
unimod and that's exactly what happens
that when the defense systems of the
unicine and are effectively down this
allows the mutants to enter into the
mind of the unimind itself it allows the
telepaths to enter in directly now this
is a major change when it comes to the
nature of mutants in Marvel Comics
something that I want to establish here
is that yes mutants and deviants do
possess similar genes and basically
mutants are descendants of deviants
hence the reason why deviants were able
to pass through the cocoan gates because
the genetic material of deviants and
mutants is close enough that there are
distant relatives essentially right
mutants are the result of humans with a
deviant Gene the difference here is that
under any normal Circumstance the
unimind is confined to eternals only the
mutants are not eternals here so under
any normal Circumstance the mutants
would never be able to enter into the
unimind and then vote for a new Prime
Eternal what's happened here is that by
hacking the firewall of the unamine and
in turn allowing other Minds to enter
into it that what this does is with the
vote being cast it cannot be done it's
irregular right Julia can't say no no no
they can't vote because they're mutants
right they're they're it doesn't count
once the vote is made the vote is
guaranteed there's no conceivable way to
undo it or to change it it doesn't
matter and so as a result of that when
the mutants vote they vote in favor of
Eros but what it does is it changes the
landscape and that Eros is voted as the
new Prime Eternal the problem with this
is that moments before the vote is cast
Druid in an act of desperation unleashes
Uranus on Earth with the belief that
Uranus in his promise would basically
solve the problem by eliminating the
mutant population and ensuring that the
the forces of Druid would remain in
control what Uranus did was abandon the
promise so the vote went through the
result of this is that Eros becomes the
new Prime Eternal and Uranus is now free
on Olympia and even free on Earth the
reason why this matters is because
remember Uranus can tap into the Armory
of the eternals in doing so quite
literally portals start opening all over
the world and just massive beings of
astronomical power begin to show up
because of the forces or the power of
Uranus to essentially summon them now
the crazy thing about this is that no
one really knows what to do here right
Iron Man is like okay we have to find a
way to essentially utilize the very
weapons of Uranus against him right what
we need is someone out there man
limitation what we need is somebody out
there that has the ability to seize
control of the very metals that Uranus
uses for his guns and arms and Armament
and all that stuff and as Uranus is
gearing up and Uranus is prepping all
these massive weapons to start opening
fire and unleashing just Hellfire on the
on the world itself the master of
magnetism appears son Magneto makes his
returns baby yes remember Magneto is one
of the people who was thought to have
been killed by uranos on Mars this guy
right the power of Magneto his heart was
ripped out of his chest this guy used
his own control over magnetism to keep
the blood flowing in his body to give
himself an artificial heart so he could
continue fighting and this guy is
incensed this guy has eight kinds of
piss and so when like when the deal is
made right like when Tony Stark hacks
into the systems into the the entire
Armory of of Uranus and he's like
Magneto are you there right the response
man you know is yes I'm ready whenever
you are right like like Tony Stark opens
the portals to the various weapons right
these just massive energy cannons that
that Uranus has and then literally all
the Cannons end up targeting uranos with
the help of Magneto and in that moment
Magneto's just like fire and then just
the whole thing just goes off and
incinerates Uranus on the Spock just
kills Uranus right there on the spot now
one of the things you remember eternals
never die they always get reserved
directed so the result of this is that
yes Uranus is destroyed in the moment
the momentary issue is quelled he's sent
back to his containment self where he
starts to reconstruct himself but lest
we forget what it was Magneto did do not
forget here when it comes to mutants
they can always be resurrected so long
as they're in the database but in order
to truly become a member of arako
society that Magneto deleted himself
from the database of krakawa meaning if
he dies there's no coming back and
Magneto dies he had just enough energy
to basically keep himself alive right
just enough power to keep himself there
and in that moment he ultimately passes
on right he ultimately ends up dying and
so as a result of this the progenitor
Celestial monitoring everything right
literally says this is the moment
Magneto could weakened he could call out
to his old friend who would still save
him I listen and there is nothing he
does not betray his promise to the
oracco people he truly is a guy who's
maintaining his role in araka right
maintaining the deal that was made he's
not a betrayer of his own word and in
turn the progenitor says he sees me as I
slip away I take on the form of the one
he thought he lost she smiles and waves
approvingly if all were like him there
would be no need for men like him but
look this is of interest to me and what
you end up having is Eros who approaches
the progenitor Celestial and the
response of Eros is this look I have
traveled the world and I have talked to
all different manner of people I have
spoke to them I've heard their words
I've made deals with them and the
reality here is that we as people can be
better we can improve we can be more
capable but we can't do it in a day we
need more than a day by tomorrow we can
become better and that's when the
progenitor is like it's time right I do
not address the world I have spoken
enough I have watched enough and I have
judged enough and I have decided you
have all lived enough if you had a
million years you'd never do enough
you'll always be better tomorrow
tomorrow things will be different
tomorrow you will improve it's always
tomorrow it's always tomorrow it's
always tomorrow and he says but you
don't realize that one day tomorrow
would run out and the progenitor judges
against the entirety of humanity and
starts eradicating all life on Earth
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end man I told
you this story was amazing thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later
peace